à l'instant c'est le ministre polonais
de l'agriculture qui qui réagit un ce
matin qui estime que la Russie utilise
ces céréales comme comme une arme on va
aller plus loin tout de suite avec vous
à mes Charlie bonjour Armel peut-être
d'abord expliquer de nouveau en quoi
consiste cet accord et surtout pourquoi
les Russes se sont opposés l'année
dernière à sa prolongation alors
pourquoi existe cet accord parce que la
l'Ukraine et la Russie mais surtout la
revue Ukraine nourrice une grande partie
du monde et quand on voit que les
céréales le blé est exporté vers les
pays africains mais bien d'autres pays
en fait et couper en fait cette
approvisionnement ça met en péril et les
gens pour avoir du pain par exemple en
Égypte en Tunisie ça allait tout de
suite été les peurs donc c'est ça qu'il
faut rappeler les exportations agricoles
ukrainiennes aujourd'hui c'est 33
millions de tonnes qui sont partis
l'année dernière et ça correspond pour
eux à 10 à 12% de leur PIB donc
l'importance est colossale et c'est pour
ça que c'est l'inscris dit on va y aller
quoi qu'il arrive de l'autre côté la
Russie elle a joué aussi cette partition
parce que elle elle vend des céréales et
surtout c'est un pays qui produit de
l'engrais comme la Biélorussie et
l'engrais on en a besoin parce qu'on ne
sait pas faire sans aujourd'hui que ce
soit dans les pays européens que ce soit
ailleurs sur la planète surtout quand il
va y avoir de la sécheresse on va avoir
besoin de cet engrais que ce soit de
l'azote que ce soit potassium que ce
soit de ammoniac peu importe les tissus
généralement les Russes les produits à
partir du gaz naturel donc on a cette
capacité là de d'exportation et ce que
dénonce les Russes c'est qu'ils disent
d'une part on a laissé passer les
céréales ukrainienne mais vous nous avez
pas permis d'avoir les mêmes
possibilités sur les engrais et sur les
céréales et ensuite on avait demandé que
soit directement concerné des pays
africains et en fait quand on regarde on
voit que c'est plutôt les Chinois les
Turcs voir des Européens qui ont pu
acheter par exemple le maïs a beaucoup
été acheté par les Italiens ou les
Espagnols en ça ils n'ont pas tout à
fait tort alors évidemment on attend des
conséquences répercussions parler en
Afrique au Moyen-Orient aussi quelles
conséquences sur l'économie mondiale
Armelle elle sera importante alors c'est
pour ça que on ne sait pas ce que ça va
donner c'est pour ça que lorsque l'on
parle de bras de fer lorsque l'on parle
effectivement de chantage oui parce que
de toute manière tous les pays ont
intérêt à ce que ça fonctionne aussi
bien la Russie et l'Ukraine qui ont
besoin de gagner de l'argent que les
autres pays qui doivent être alimentés
derrière clairement si les Ukrainiens
veulent passer outre le blocus le risque
c'est que les Russes tirent sur les
bateaux quand ils sont effectivement en
mer Noire est-ce qu'ils le feront est-ce
qu'ils le feront sur un bateau est-ce
qu'ils continueront le faire sur
d'autres voilà la question mais la
crispation elle est énorme parce que
aujourd'hui quand vous aviez eu cet
accord qui a été signé par les Turcs en
fait si on regardait clairement beaucoup
de choses avaient déjà eu et c'est la
même chose que pour le gaz et le pétrole
par exemple pour les engrais la campagne
des pandages elle avait déjà eu lieu en
fait c'est la saison 23 24 qui va avoir
lieu là si elle se passe dans ce creux
là la difficulté elle sera très
importante à ce niveau là et pour
l'instant on n'a pas les moyens de
trouver une alternative même si le
commerce est moindre même si on commence
à avoir un certain nombre de pays qui
ont pu travailler aussi bien sur les
engrais que sur les céréales mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore
d'alternative merci beaucoup Armelle
pour le décryptage à l'heure où donc cet
accord à expirer fin de cette édition
merci